tous les ans
depuis quelques jours les acheteurs
d'armes se ruent dans les magasins
normalement me réserve
comme n'importe quel commerçant garde
des stocks et la réserve est détendue au
complet petit avec ce qui reste dans les
vitrines des tours ça c'est en deux
jours et on rouvre la classe partout au
québec la nouvelle mouture du projet de
loi c 21 sur les armes à feu pousse les
amateurs à se procurer une arme
[Musique]
lundi dernier ottawa a annoncé un gel
national de la vente l'achat et le
transfert des armes de poing au pays
d'ici l'automne seuls les tireurs qui
ont déjà une arme pour on l'a conservée
mais seuls clients qui m'ont pas vu
c'est sûr qu'ils en ont présent
contrairement aux états unis la
réglementation entourant la possession
d'une arme de poing et strictes une
pratique réglementé qui ne se déploie
exclusivement dans les clubs de tir
c'est toute une industrie qui est en
péril c'est sûr et certain qu'on a rompu
le nouveau tireur si je suis capable
d'avoir des armes donc l'entreprise aux
salaires décroissance moi j'ai investi
avec trois partenaires 1.3 million il ya
treize ans passés
je vous reprocherai très bon augure
qu'est ce qui se passe présentement
l'objectif du gouvernement est de
freiner l'augmentation de la violence
par armes à feu des experts croient
qu'il manque sa cible en s'attaquant aux
armes de poing évidemment ces enveloppes
peuvent être volés perdu
ce site tandis que tous les corps de
police au canada c'est
l'essentiel des armes sont retrouvés sur
les scènes de crime dans les rues des
grandes villes canadiennes
bien sûr la frontière agissons pour
réduire la criminalité dit eric en
évitant de punir les amateurs d'armes
légitime c'est
de donner des ressources aux policiers
le contrôle aux frontières c'est
toujours ça c'est du travail de rue knox
après yarden mais c'est parce que
politiquement c'est pour baigner toute
l'industrie espère qu'ottawa changera
son fusil d épaule ici marie josée
paquet comme radio-canada l'assomption